[Music]
season two is finally here when you got
your hands on those first scripts what
was your reaction I love you say scripts
script that's all we had to begin with
what soso did you say what was your
reaction when you read that first script
I literally can't tell you that I was
completely shell-shocked it was
absolutely not what I thought was gonna
happen I have a really good relationship
with Jonah and Lisa we're friends I
don't want them to tell me things I like
not knowing I'm not one of those people
that needs to know everything I like it
I as an actress too it's you know I
don't want to be thinking too much about
it ahead of time because I've got so
much else in my life as well as being an
actress you know mom and you know what
other things so I kind of like but I did
have a sense because of where we left in
season one I I just assumed it would be
a kind of direct continuation and it is
nuts nuts we know there's a little bit
of a time jump let me pick up um well we
do pick up where we left off okay she's
on the hunt for her daughter
how does she reconcile the fact that
maybe that daughter that's what we think
yes the assumption is she's on the hunt
burger that's the assumption and that
it's an assumption okay I'll take it's
an assumption yeah
how much is Maeve working on her free
will in season two because we were under
the assumption that she was working
under free will then we find out she was
programmed to escape well um as far as I
know because I really don't know as far
as I know because this has this has you
know really muscular legs this show I
think it's I think the Lisa and Jonah
have a sense of what's what's gonna
happen you know five seasons ahead
I think they've always known which is
why it was such a shock to kind of
begin the the next step of that journey
because it really wasn't what I expected
as far as I guess Maeve knows or we know
she has a degree of of command over what
she's doing but because I'm so flummoxed
by you know the second season in a
really good way you know it's like I'm
really paying attention now I'm really
paying attention like it's season one I
was just like emotionally like it was
like I was on a on a trip you know like
a knit like a spiritual trip with Maeve
and now I'm like my brain is kicked
right in with season two okay no that's
that for me I know it's so vague but
yeah what was your number one question
left over from season one my number one
question from season one was what is
gonna happen to Dolores okay that's a
big question well what's what's Dolores
gonna let happen to Dolores okay yeah
yeah I would say that did you get your
answer that would be giving too much
away you're well-trained I'm not trained
I yeah I guess well I've just been told
what to say and well not not to what to
say but I've been told what not to say
got it and I think it's right I do I
think we're all here right now to get
excited about the show I don't think
anybody
I mean people of course they think they
want to know but it's it's delayed
gratification let's enjoy discovering it
I think you know where we're at now with
social media and with access to so much
information you know we do we're
addicted to finding stuff out but there
is a really beautiful feeling that comes
over you if you just wait and allow it
allow it you know I remember when I was
a kid every Wednesday
it was Dallas on television and it was
the one time in the week when just me
and my mum would do something like that
together we'd watch TV together and it
was you know it makes me kind of
emotional just thinking about it and
I used to love waiting for it and I
looked forward to it and when it came it
was so exciting delayed gratification is
a beautiful thing and we're losing it
and you know I don't think that the
generation today you know the current
generation even knows what that feels
like anymore and I would you know
strongly recommend trying to bring it
back
people love waiting they do they get
excited about it builds up the
anticipation is is delicious if you had
to sum up season two with just one word
what would your one word be please okay
unexpected
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]